oh I should gotta ask questions like
this well uh
[Music]
oh okay I had a bad childhood so that's
a lot I kind of wish I never heard what
people think about me because it really
changes my perspective on myself and it
kind of drags my confidence down a lot
of people talk about like my way or like
how I look and honestly like I feel like
if people kept their opinions to
themselves like that would be a lot more
helpful but people are just opinionated
I guess when I was five years old my mom
told me I was going to die and I
remember being very shocked and I really
got upset because it was the first time
that I realized I was going to die when
my doctor told me I had Stage two lung
cancer that would probably be one of the
big ones
this was in October of last year I'm in
college so I went to my local Wellness
Center when I started coughing up blood
actually and then they referred me to a
doctor who and diagnosed me and I
remember walking in and it was kind of
your classic like doctor on one side he
sit on the other side and he looks all
somber and so I kind of went into shock
I had taken public transportation to the
doctors so I took public transportation
back and I was just like in my seat just
zoning out and then I remember getting
back calling my boyfriend at the time
telling him the news and just sitting
there in silence
after that call ended I just like burst
into tears I was like well what do I do
now like I had so many plans and like
now I don't know if I'll even be here to
do them
I remember going back into my dorm and
having to tell my suitemates
and having to comfort them and then
going back into my own room and just
trying to decide how to reprioritize my
dad had non-small-cell lung cancer and I
had small cell lung cancer so we thought
maybe it might be genetics but it wasn't
connected I don't smoke
very young so we still don't know my
family encouraged me to drop out of
school which I refused to do because
it's really important to me that I
graduate in four years so I stayed in
school and then
he goes like four or five months later
beat cancer technically finish my
semester didn't fail any classes is this
which is good and I've been in remission
ever since so hopefully I never have to
hear that again if that was around my
birthday - actually my 20th birthday I
was like a week before I think this is
the best birthday present I've ever
gotten mm-hmm like just being able to go
back and tell people you know they
didn't have to worry about me anymore at
least for now
I was incredible it was freedom it was a
lot of freedom to not be scared to
pursue what I wanted to do my childhood
best friend passed away of cancer when
he was just 21 or 22 and for very long
time was very passionate about being an
airline pilot and he was like probably
one of the most what kind of prodigy so
he he he like was able to go through
like high school really quickly and he
was known as the baby pilot because he
was he was able to become a lion pilot
so young and he has such a baby face
that people could not believe it he was
already a line pilot but then very soon
after that he was not even diagnosed he
just was walking I think in in Dubai Abu
Dhabi Connors on a flight trip and he
just collapsed on the flow and it turned
out that he had like a cancer doing his
back and it was just terminal actually
has changed a bit the way I choose my
career now I work in the last two
company I worked in was all related with
cancer they realized that cancer is a
very common thing that may be one of
three people in your life will probably
suffer in their lifetime and so I work
on early cancer detection I've been so
many many improvements that with our
generational thing
diseases that I think we could even
educate the right people and the right
Nanami
can you describe your best friend to ice
the best you can
yeah it was just like a bubbly happy guy
just always in a good mood and very
positive maybe not the most extroverted
but very passionate I feel like I've I
found my passion maybe later in life but
he knew from the beginning that he
wanted to fly planes I think it's always
amazing to see people have such
convention and what they want to do and
pursue that and make it happen and never
give up on their childhood dreams your
childhood dream is like you know you
listen lest you bring or to your mind
when you listen to your heart and after
as you get older you listen more to your
mind and rationalize yourself out of
things that you know is right for you
but you just can't lose track of that I
think he never lost track of what his
passion of what he wanted as a kid and
did it although he didn't live very long
I think life worth living is not counted
in like years right it's more about what
you do what you become
doesn't matter how it is I think his
life was every second of it and made it
count I wish I would have never heard or
at least read the suicide notes of a boy
in my class about the way our school
treated him and why he did what he did
he just said that at least like the
neighborhood we lived in and the
community we lived in put too much
pressure on kids to go to the right
school to go in the same pathway to go
to college after high school and how
note none of the teacher support in him
and then of the adults that had
Authority would listen to him but it's
really cause change in my school which
is a positive result but also I I didn't
really want to know that kids were going
I wish I had never heard that my friends
sometimes use me crazy
all my life I've liked her like about
racism I learned about it I've studied
it it was like kind of unique topic to
me because like I never understood why
other people would look at other people
a certain way and try to control them
just because they were different colors
and they were but like everyone's a
person like you have an eyes and those
teeth ears a heart and everyone should
be the same I think that one's equal and
you're not higher than anyone else one
thing is we were talking about it this
morning is I wish I never heard that the
devil was real or that like even
anything about the devil as a child I
wish I wish I never heard about about
how meat was made or is man
because I like to eat meat but I also
don't wanna don't want to add to animal
cruelty but it's so good I wished I
never heard that Santa was real because
since I was little I got two things one
thing my house doesn't have a chimney
and two things how does one man know
when seven billion people are sleeping
why it makes no sense and I'm a very
logical person
good I don't want my little brother to
be discouraged or anything so I'm just
gonna act like he's really you know rude
words do you have any specific ones in
mind no and if I had I wouldn't say them
you might want to get tested probably
that you're not college material
you ever who told you that my
grandmother I personally think that
everybody is college material it's just
coming from like lower classes like hard
yeah obviously my gonna go to Harvard
who is Harvard rich people not me she
sells the same thing to my sister she
tells me like your sister's not college
material you can't say that to someone
because it's gonna discourage them from
going to college I'm already gonna
graduate with my bachelor's debt-free
and I've traveled the world and so
anybody can do it it really discourages
someone to say that and I was like I
want to go get my PhD and I want to do
all these things but it always kind of
sticks in the back of my mind like
you're not calling material you're not
gonna get there I am I wish I never
heard the term fake news because I feel
like the people who worked so hard go to
college they try to be so fair and
balanced in their reporting so that's
it's their life and ever since this fake
news rumor started nobody has a belief
anymore in institutions and the news
media in their leaders and so the whole
belief system is eroded in that's that's
what I wish I had never heard we don't
have enough money I'm a teacher and I'm
from Arizona and legislators are always
saying they don't have enough money to
fund our education system and as a
result our children are going to be
illiterate the teachers don't stay more
than a year and they all go and I'm I
would they have enough money they're not
using it to take care of of what needs
to be taken care they put it in the
rainy day fund but it's already raining
I wish I hadn't heard my dad
like talk about how much he cheated on
my mom I don't know because like I saw
him differently ever since I wish I
never had all the story of so many
religions in this wall because I don't
believe in religions I believe there is
one God what I don't believe in
religions religion separate brothers
sisters friends create trouble to others
but if you go through all of them which
have been in all of them everybody said
God is good so there's only one God
there's not a witness that's my own
belief today my answer kind of answers
the question but it's a bit of a variety
it's more of one thing that I've heard
repeatedly that I would like to have not
hurt so hopefully that counts something
that I wouldn't have liked to hear is
any time my dad kind of yells at my mom
in like a negative way or if she makes
like a mistake or if she slips up
anywhere even though she's just trying
to do the right thing my dad kind of
gets angry at her so I think any time
that's happened I would have enjoyed not
having
I feel like a terrible bystander just
watching something bad happen like I
love my mom I let my dad my dad isn't a
bad person by any means he's actually a
great person so as my mom she just has
good intentions and sometimes the
execution doesn't work out well which is
just unfortunate and I think we all have
that sort of empathy where if you see
someone trying really hard but they
don't quite you know achieve whatever it
is that they're trying to do that you
just feel bad for them because you know
you tell everyone oh if you try as long
as you're trying everything's fine but
you know there's obviously incidents
where you're trying and things don't
work out and that really sucks and
there's nothing you can do about it like
you know I think that's a hard question
for me specifically because with the way
my personality is I would always I would
always rather know even if it hurts like
recently maybe a month or two ago I
learned that my dad has cancer
and he didn't tell me I learned from an
ex actually and my dad still hasn't told
me about it and I'm I mean I don't know
if he's ever gonna tell me or I'll learn
at his funeral but I'm glad I know I'm
glad it's not like gonna come out of
nowhere and blindside me life hurts and
like sometimes I hurts to be alive and
sometimes it hurts to get bad news and
sometimes like sometimes things are like
something sometimes everything is just
gonna be but like you can't come to
terms with something you don't know
about hey guys thanks for watching
another episode if you haven't
subscribed to my channel yet please make
sure to hit the subscribe button and a
little ball next to it so you'll get
notified every time I put up a new
episode and if you have some friends
that you think might also like the
episodes it would mean a lot if you
shared my episodes with them as well if
you want I think that's pretty much it
thank you guys again and I'll see you
next week
[Music]